nous sommes sur la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en compagnie
de lionel masse et à bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le directeur du théâtre
alors avant de parler de la
programmation la saison à venir un 2021
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dresser le
bilan des études ont en quelques mots ça
a été une saison comme vous l'imaginez
un peu étrange où beaucoup de choses se
sont déroulées en dehors du théâtre
puisqu'on à continuer à intervenir en
tournée itinérante dans les
établissements scolaires des yvelines
on a continué toutes les actions que
l'on mène avec les artistes en dehors du
en dehors du théâtre et le théâtre a lui
même été assez actif puisqu'on est à peu
près quatre mois de répétitions alors le
théâtre ferme ses portes vent le 23
juillet la ministre vous pouvez nous
parler de la programmation de cet été
qui a différent peut-être spectacles qui
sont joués alors un des avantages de
cette fermeture au public c'est que ça
nous a laissé un tout petit peu de temps
pour mettre en place certains chantiers
dont le chantier des escapades
l'année dernière on avait appelé ça
l'été culturel il ya eu trois concerts à
port royal là on a essayé d'être plus
ambitieux et artistiquement et
géographiquement puisqu'il va y avoir 10
ou 11 spectacles de qui ont commencé
d'ailleurs le 26 27 juin à port royal
avec une adaptation des trois
mousquetaires qui vont se poursuivre
jusqu'au 10 7 au 18 septembre prochain
quand même une petite interruption
pendant pendant cet été mais on va on va
jouer à l'extérieur 10 11 12 spectacles
à l'art vendredi 10 septembre c'est du
coup le l'inauguration a en tout cas de
la nouvelle saison 2021 2022 ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer un truc quel est
le programme
ou est-ce qu'on rêvait de faire depuis
un petit moment et qu'on n'avait pas pu
mettre en place c'est faire une grande
soirée d'ouverture de la saison avec un
vernissage donc vendredi 10 septembre à
partir de 18 heures il y aura le
vernissage d'une exposition qui
s'appelle anima ex musica qui
l'exposition qui va qu'on va conserver
pendant à peu près à peu près en moi qui
est assez exceptionnel puisque ce sont
des artistes des plasticiens qui recrée
des animaux en taille géante pas des
animaux des insectes des araignées des
arachnides à partir d'instruments de
musique qui ne sont plus utilisés
donc il y aura cette exposition qui sera
dans tout le théâtre
pendant un mois à partir du 10 septembre
ensuite il y aura une brève présentation
de saison d'à peu près une heure et
ensuite les publics pourront aller sur
le quai françois truffaut pour voir un
spectacle encore spectacle de funambules
qui s'appelle résistent qui a été répété
d'ailleurs qui devaient être joués sur
cette scène dans le courant de l'année
on a conservé le temps de répétition et
se sera jouée le 10 et 11 septembre
vendredi 10 et samedi 11 septembre à
20h30 qui est françois truffaut donc
voilà ça permet d'avoir une soirée assez
complète et bien c'est noté on sera là
merci beaucoup pour tout ces
informations